[Música]
empezar haciéndoles una pregunta
y es a quienes les molesta ver una calle
llena de basura sin timidez levanten la
mano
a mí no
ya les voy a explicar por qué para mí es
muy inquietante ver una calle limpia
porque en este momento siendo la
situación que se que eso significa que
hay mucha basura que está muy bien
escondida es decir el problema no se ha
resuelto sino que estaba solo
cómodamente oculto a nuestros ojos
entonces para contarles de dónde viene
esta visión particular de la basura me
tengo que volver varias décadas para
atrás cuando tenía 7 u 8 años empecé un
club ecológico para mis amiguitos a mí
me preocupa el planeta y yo quería hacer
lo que estuviera en mis manos no me
parecía que tuviera sentido sentarme a
esperar a que las soluciones vinieran
solamente de afuera y en ese entonces
una de las cosas que promovía como
práctica del cuidado del planeta era
precisamente poner la basura en la
basura entonces en todos estos años que
han pasado desde ese momento pues mi
visión y mi práctica del cuidado del
planeta han cambiado un montón
particularmente mi visión de la basura y
en ese sentido ahora a mí no me parece
que esconder la basura en una basurero
sea una manera de cuidar el planeta de
hecho me parece que es todo lo contrario
porque que la basura está escondida nos
da la ilusión de que el problema no
existe y por lo tanto nos sentimos
necesidad de resolverlo
entonces en este proceso de querer hacer
lo que está en mis manos empezaba a
cambiar radicalmente mi relación con la
basura y en ese proceso he aprendido
mucho de mí misma yo sé que eso suena
muy raro pero la verdad es que la basura
dice muchísimo y nosotros habla
nuestras aficiones habla de nuestros
hábitos habla de nuestros miedos de
nuestras inseguridades y me acuerdo
mucho de un momento en mi infancia en el
que estaba viendo una serie de
detectives y una escena en la que
descubrían quién era el culpable por lo
que había en la basura y yo creo que ahí
empezó todo este rollo porque desde ese
momento en adelante siempre he tenido
como curiosidad y paranoia de pensar que
podría averiguar alguien de mí por el
contenido de mi basurero
entonces si yo veo esta escena del
crimen
y veo mi basurero
yo creo que un detective no tendría que
ser muy buen detective para llegar a la
conclusión de que yo soy una de las
culpables y yo no quiero seguir
aportando a eso es cierto yo no quiero
formar parte de lo que está generando
este tipo de crímenes entonces me he
puesto el objetivo de aprender a vivir
con tan poca basura como sea posible
ese proceso que ha sido de varios años
no ha sido para nada una cosa de la
noche a la mañana llega a un punto en el
que tener una basura en mi casa ha
dejado de tener sentido y entonces he
empezado
a guardar mi basura en un frasco de
vidrio esto no fue una idea mía o sea es
algo que copié de otras personas que veo
que están en esta misma búsqueda de que
guardan su basura en un frasco de vidrio
y para mí al principio era pues pensaba
que era una cuestión de tamaño cómoda
así es porque es pequeño pero después me
di cuenta que el material era esencial
que es transparente y el hecho de que
esto sea transparente a mí me ha traído
por lo menos dos grandes revelaciones
que son cosas
como bastante obvias pero son el tipo de
cosas en las que uno no se detiene a
pensar en la vida cotidiana entonces la
primera revelación es que a los humanos
nos molesta la basura solamente cuando
la vemos generamos montones de basura
pero entonces la metemos en unas bolsas
la mandamos en un camión tan lejos de
nosotros como sea posible
de hecho mientras tenemos la basura en
la caja la tenemos guardada en bolsas
negras en recipientes opacos o sea no
queremos ni siquiera ver nuestra propia
basura ya no soportamos la presencia de
nuestra propia basura y sin embargo la
manera que tenemos de lidiar con este
asunto es cómo los niños chiquitos que
se tapan los ojos y piensan que el
monstruo se desapareció cuando yo lo que
creo es que a estas alturas deberíamos
tener una mirada más adulta y entender
que el hecho de que no estamos viendo un
problema directamente no significa que
el problema no exista
la otra revelación es que también es
bastante obvia es que cada vez que voy a
meter un poquito de basura en ese frasco
el resto de la basura que han generado
sigue estando ahí como mirándome y
recordándome que ahí hay un problema que
yo no he resuelto ya que la basura no se
ha desaparecido como tampoco se habría
desaparecido si yo la hubiera mandado en
relleno sanitario y como tampoco se
desaparecen los 240 kilos de basura que
se calcula que genera un ciudadano común
al año los 240 kilos de basuras es como
si yo generara 4 veces mi propio peso de
basura al año eso es una barbaridad y el
asunto es que hemos normalizado tanto la
basura hemos llegado a un punto en el
que creemos que es inevitable y en el
que creemos que es natural cuando
realmente lo natural es que la basura no
exista en la naturaleza nada se
desaprovecha entonces si miramos a
nuestro alrededor vemos que por ejemplo
lo que le sobra a un depredador lo
aprovecha un carroñero lo que le sobra
un carroñero lo aprovechan unos insectos
de lo que le sobra a los insectos lo
aprovechan los microorganismos del suelo
que lo convierten en nutrientes para las
plantas y todo el ciclo sigue y este
asunto de que haya como elementos que
sobran que estorban que no se
aprovecharon y que contaminan es un
problema exclusivamente humano y es un
problema pues que yo pienso que tenemos
que resolver y que creo que tiene que
ver con nuestra percepción y con nuestra
actitud también ahí hay un problema de
diseño pero ese es un tema para otro día
y creo que la percepción tiene por un
lado que ver con las palabras que
elegimos usar porque por ejemplo decimos
relleno sanitario en lugar de decir
basurero cuando un relleno sanitario
pues básicamente es un basurero lo que
pasa es que suena más bonito o elegimos
decir residuo en lugar de decir recurso
desaprovechado porque cuando decimos
recurso desaprovechado estamos hablando
ahí de una responsabilidad de alguien de
que alguien el fallo en aprovechar algo
mientras que cuando decimos residuos es
ahí como en el aire y como que no es
elegimos decir como reciclamos el 10% de
los residuos cuando queríamos decir
estamos fracasando en el 90% del
aprovechamiento de residuos porque claro
la primera nos levanta el ego y la
segunda no
entonces
en este proceso de conectar con esa con
esa percepción y con esa actitud creo
que hay otro asunto que es muy
importante y es la dificultad que
tenemos para entender el impacto
acumulativo tanto positivo como negativo
de las cosas pequeñas entonces voy a
poner un ejemplo puntual un vaso
desechable un vaso desechable es pequeño
no pesa casi nada no ocupa casi nada
espacio es ridículamente barato
y uno dice pues es un vaso desechable no
importa pero entonces hagamos un cálculo
rápido pensemos que una persona usa en
promedio tres vasos desechables por
semana tirando por lo bajo porque sé que
hay gente que usa muchísimo más que eso
pero con esos tres vasos por semana esa
persona ya no estamos hablando de un
solo vaso sino que al año bota la basura
156 vasos ya es un número más grande
pero sigue sin ser un número escandaloso
entonces ya no pensemos en una sola
persona sino que pensemos en la mitad de
la población del valle de aburrá tirando
por lo bajo de nuevo porque seguramente
más de la mitad usa vasos desechables
pero con la mitad de la población ya no
estamos hablando de 156 vasos sino de
296 millones 400 mil vasos tirados a la
basura al año y se pues evidentemente no
es un cálculo que hice aquí me lo
aprendí para la charla pero lo pueden
calcular fácilmente y comprobar
y eso es o sea es una monstruosidad
entonces pensemos cuánto genera
antioquia cuánto colombia cuánto
suramérica cuánto el mundo y eso o sea
yo cuando pienso en esas cifras digo qué
basurero
y qué impotencia y qué crimen y qué
hacemos con eso entonces hay gente que
dice no pues los reciclamos pero el
asunto es que el reciclaje no resuelve
el problema sino que solamente se ocupa
de los síntomas o sea es como ponerle un
paño de agua tibia a la persona con una
enfermedad mortal
y entonces realmente que podemos hacer o
sea no se necesita una innovación local
inesperada
sino algo tan sencillo como esto dejar
de usar vasos desechables entonces con
esta tácita que yo llevo conmigo a todas
partes que tampoco pesa nada y que
además es súper barata
significa esa tasa significa que yo ya
nunca más he tenido que usar un vaso
desechable nunca más ni uno
yo creo que
[Música]
hay una cosa muy importante y es pensar
que si queremos resolver ese problema
los kilos y kilos de basura que estamos
generando
hay algunas cosas que dependen de
iniciativas gubernamentales y de
iniciativas industriales hay mucho eso
que está en nuestras manos para mí la
lógica es que si yo no quiero ver la
basura que si yo no estoy dispuesta a
acumular 240 kilos de basura en mi casa
pues en lugar de esconderlo a lo que
debería estar haciendo es dejar de
generarlo
y eso lo puede hacer cualquier persona o
sea lo he logrado yo que soy una persona
común y corriente entonces yo sé que hay
muchas personas y le dicen no es que ya
vive generando poca basura se imagina
que yo vivo en una cueva que no me baño
que me pinto la cara con barro pero pues
yo soy una persona tan común y corriente
como se puede hacer ese hecho uso
internet amo internet
tengo amigos me baño
he logrado generar un cambio muy
significativo se ha pasado de generar no
sé cuánto porque antes no la pesaba pero
supongamos que esos 240 kilos 240 kilos
al año más o menos un kilo he pasado de
lo normal que sacar unas dos bolsas de
basura por semana para que cada seis
meses saca una bolsa de basura de este
tamaño
sigo generando basura así pero estoy
generando menos y hay gente que me dice
cómo hay pero es que no estás cambiando
el mundo y yo sé o sea yo sé que yo no
estoy cambiando el mundo yo no lo puedo
cambiar sola ojalá yo estoy tratando de
ser coherente con las cosas que a mí me
importan y estoy además haciendo un
ejercicio de observación y de reflexión
yo me estoy como convirtiendo en una
detective de mí misma para entender
mejor mi relación con la basura mis
patrones de consumo y el tipo de huella
que estoy dejando en el planeta y
también hay gente que me hace así como
un escaneo general y dice ahí celular
tus tenis no sé es igual estás generando
impacto y yo sé que estoy generando
impacto o sea yo no lo puedo hacer todo
pero para mí el hecho de que yo no puedo
hacer todo
jamás es una excusa para sentarme a
hacer absolutamente nada entonces a
pesar de esos comentarios
yo elijo quedarme con mi frasco de
vidrio y con lo que esta transparencia
representa en un mundo en el que nos
hemos acostumbrado a tapar los problemas
ya cruzar los dedos para no tener que
lidiar con ellos después yo creo que
esta es mi manera cómo enfrentarme a una
sociedad que esconde su basura en bolsas
negras y yo espero que este frasco y la
transparencia que acaba sirva para
motivar a otras personas a quitarle ese
velo tan cómodo y tan peligroso que le
ponemos a la basura entonces si con esto
que les estoy contando esto no fuera ya
una campanita en la cabeza y dicen si yo
quiero pero no sé por dónde empezar la
tarea es demasiado grande recuerden que
los cambios grandes siempre empiezan con
cosas pequeñas
y que a veces la solución no son
innovaciones inesperadas sino cosas que
ya tenemos guardadas en el gabinete de
la cocina muchas gracias
[Aplausos]